salut enfin les casse-têtes reviennent
en 2022 sur la chaîne sachez que vous
auriez dû y avoir un casse tête
incroyable qui arrivent ici le plus gros
casse tête de la chaîne ça devait être
la semaine dernière mais loïc et devenir
le vide mais ne vous inquiétez pas on en
a plein d'autres alain celui qui m'avait
envoyé celui-là il ya quelques temps il
avait l'air très très relou voulait pas
trop me confronter mes skis coup j'ai
pas le choix de le faire aujourd'hui
loïc génériques
[Musique]
et juste avant de détruire ma patience
sachez que la vidéo d'aujourd'hui est
sponsorisé par north vpn qui continuent
à nous soutenir en 2022 souvenez-vous de
leur rue pnc le vpn avec 14 millions
d'utilisateurs à travers le monde le
plus rapide du marché est l'un des rares
disponible sur toutes les principales
plateformes en français est sympa c'est
quand même super pratique donc si vous
cherchez un avp n est bien guim ne
cherchez plus que vous soyez dans un
wifi public dans un bar à la fat ou en
voyage nord au bn va protéger votre
navigation mais pas seulement avec leur
bébé n vous pouvez aussi élargir votre
catalogue de contenus disponibles sur
votre télévision ou sur vos plates
formes de streaming préféré oui par
exemple pour voir le nouveau marvel par
exemple et tout ça en plus sur six
écrans simultanément et en plus de ça si
vous avez le moindre souci vous avez
accès à un service client 24 heures sur
24 7 jours sur 7 en français ça c'est
plutôt pas mal et une garantie de
remboursement de 30 jours donc en plus
essayez norvez pnc sans engager le lien
bernard vpn est en description vous
allez en plus bénéficié d'une grosse
réduction très importante pour une durée
limitée alors merci nord dpn merci de
continuer à nous suivre parce que le
prochain gros casse-tête vous souvenez
du casse-tête à 15000 euros un bas
c'était de la gnognotte à côté du
prochain casse tête donc merci à eux
parce que c'est aussi grâce à ses
sponsors là qu'on arrive à vous faire ce
genre de vidéos alors pourquoi j'ai déjà
envie d'insulter ce casse tête avant de
commencer d'incompris principe j'ai deux
baguettes il ya un espèce de truc en
plastique laqué à l'intérieur il n'y a
pas de consignes mais on l'a compris la
consigne pour réussir à sortir ça et ça
commence très bien
donc là ça ne passe pas
si je le prends sur le côté ça passe pas
non plus par contre là je vois qu'il ya
des en cloche un peu et j'entends déclic
dans le dans le bi nous ça ça sent les
pico à l'intérieur qui
si je le lève dans ce sens là
on entend des trucs dedans là des
petites bible des petits picots ça
ressemble à des casse têtes qu'on
connaît c'est à dire ou août à des
picots d'un côté qui rentre dans le trou
et qui t'empêche de les défaire pas les
casse-têtes d'agilité ça me gonfle grave
moi je préfère les boîtes main préférée
pour vous c'est quoi vous cassent les
prêts fleurs est ce que ces gens les
trucs ça se défait tout seul et tu dois
leur faire est ce que ces genres les
bois parce que ces genres les trucs
d'agilité c'est à moi ça me rappelle
vachement le le cigare que j'avais fait
sur la chaîne de cigares de churchill
qui était dans une flasque envers pareil
qui n'avait pia sous l' axe ça il faut
que je les désolidarise l'allée de
l'aller deux matches ça fait ça comme ça
en boîte et l'un dans l'autre et moi je
pense que l'un dans l'autre là je pense
qu'il ya des petits picots qui rentre
dans un sens ou dans un autre et qui
font enlever alors je vais en faire
appel un casse-tête en métal qu'on avait
eue c'était une boîte c'est une boîte
qu'on avait eu aussi quitter comme ça la
force centrifuge
dans sa tombe pas vite je me dis si je
le fais tourner assez vite et qu'il ya
des picots de chaque côté en tournant
très vite les petits qu ils vont
s'écarter vous prenez le lead et
ça ça doit être bien agréable pour vous
est ce qui coûte aux écouteurs la
fête si ça bloque net ça va commettre
les pico dedans
ok là j'ai essayé en tournant sur la
gauche peut-être en tournant sur la
droite
[Musique]
en fait si je ne relève pas d'un coup
sec
mais c'est pas des machines qu'ils l'ont
mis dedans ça veut dire il ya un mec qui
s'est fait chier à mettre dedans
ben moi non plus mon frère j'ai créé un
instagram oh mon chat c'est un soir où
je m'ennuyais et puis je me sui bat ce
pauvre petit à mal les dunes basculé peu
profond
oh
[Musique]
oh oh donc à l'arrêt je n'ai pas fait
ça il faut que je crois en moi je
croyais pas en moi je vous parle de
l'insta g de tamalous et pendant ce
temps là je le défi attend parce que des
faire un casse tête toi même tu sais
c'est la phase une
répétons cette phrase un casse tête
n'est résolu que quand il a été remis
dans son état d'origine va pas se mentir
c'est plutôt content d'avoir réussi à
faire sens là je ne vous cache pas que
je suis à deux doigts de prendre le truc
pour leur tournée que ça sort tout seul
mais on va jouer le jeu
qu'est ce que ça donne ah ouais pas
[ __ ] c'est pervers de fou en fait
regarder ça c'est la position dans
laquelle il s'est ouvert si tu fais ça
comme ça d'un pico qui tu sors d'ici
équivalent à mais si tu fais ça dans
l'autre sens si un autre picot comme ça
qui prend le relais la force centrifuge
était la bonne idée [ __ ] je pensais
pas le trouver si rapidement donc là ok
là c'est verrouillé
et là s'est déverrouillé dans ce style
est quand même
par contre si tu fais le moindre
mouvement
c'est le bloc direct parce que ça sorte
ça va falloir réussir à le remettre
dedans
on y croit moyen que comme on veut je
pense que ça avait donc là il faut lui
est comme ça faut bien qu'un derby soit
debout quoi c'est peut-être pour ça
qu'ils ont fait le trou et pour m'aider
m'isoler jamais les phrases que je dis
quand je parle de trucs comme ça yanbu
rouge qui est à l'extérieur
[Musique]
ouais là c'est pas mal lui il est prêt
lui à la limite il faudrait peut-être
que je le mette d'abord comme ça dedans
ça mais après si je le mets comme ça de
danse ça marche pas dans sa rivale m pas
reçu si j'arrive d'admettre part au
dessus je fais des tests à excusez-moi
si j'arrive à mettre au dessus de
l'autre et je le fais tourner un coup
veille tombant fait de tout ce qui fait
alors j'essaie ouais parce que je peux
pas le faire descendre comme ça je suis
obligé en fait qui se referme dans la
descente comment je m'en sors
même si j'arrive après lemaitre comme sa
part au dessus est ce que je pourrais
tripatouiller ça peut-être peut-être
peut-être peut-être peut-être peut-être
comme ça
[Musique]
c'est quoi vous avez un besoin de faire
un docteur maboule
m c est la rate
voilà je parle plus les gains
financiers afin de sauver le monde ouvre
aujourd'hui dans neuf secondes avec le
portrait d'un homme fabien sauciflard
qui sauve le monde avec des baguettes
comment en est il arrivé en train de
faire ça les jeux les poser sur le côté
lui le bloc là-haut
et g7 versa c'est un casse tête qui et
cinq sur cinq en difficulté et en
agilité en plus que je déteste si on y
arrive on est fiers quoi un jeu pourtant
je trouve que c'est pas mal parce que
lui comme il est dedans je suis sûr que
ça se referme pas
par contre je crois qu il faut
il montre pas plus
oh merde cris panique
si j'arrive
au nom si près de d'un truc au départ et
elle est toute assez c'est quand même
très conforme ou
est ce qu'il ya des mecs on ne fait pas
une enfance difficile et sont dit tiens
je vais créer ça et moi aussi j'ai bien
le danger l'espèce humaine a mais il est
bloqué vous que trouve
[Musique]
fait kiffer la dernière rotation qui
rend ouf
en fait là où ça est vraiment cdc des
pervers je te le dis moi c'est que ils
ont fait des les bâtons que vous ne
voyez utilisés sont des bâtons tu peux
pas serrer avec des bâtons ou alors
peut-être si je le jette par terre
très violemment et que je pars peut-être
c'est ça la bonne résolution
[ __ ] il m'a rendu au free
ok lui après quand j'étais dessus vous
n'arrivez pas à aller refermer
publiquement pourquoi parce qu'ils ont
un sens peut-être il ya un sens le temps
que j'ai c'est que je fasse mes tests
l'intestin cessé d'offrir à l'intérieur
j'arrivais pas l'ouvrir et ouais [ __ ]
il est bloqué on est donc il ya 100 sans
plus sans déconner tu vois la vache il y
avait un sens moi j'ai même pas
peut-être animal comme si je me sens si
je voulais le manger bob
[Musique]
vous vous dites c'est pas mal évidemment
moi aussi j'ai une émotion particulière
mais les pico était sorti
non on va pas se mentir ça me plaisait
bien
ok là et il est rentré mais pas comme il
faut c'est à dire que tous les petits qu
ils sont bien rentrés [ __ ] je touche
un truc là si je la rive
[Musique]
binger al
qadr et cette phrase je
prends comme ça
[Musique]
guerre parce que je recommande ce sens
ben voilà on arrête là
[Musique]
oui merde
sur les coups qu genre de casse têtes
basses
castes est résolu castets relooke semé
car ce cas car cette carte et ouais cast
est possible bon là j'ai pas mis trop de
temps par rapport à si j'avais pas connu
l'astuce des trucs de forces centrifuges
mais même une fois tu la connais ça
t'empêche pas que en fait ça te met un
sommes immenses c'est quand tu tues tu
t'es en train de faire un truc c'était
super délicat et juste à cause d'un bond
arrondies ou fois ça ouais et ça c'est
le genre de truc qui t'énerve comme le
genre de truc qui vous énerve parce que
j'ai pour autoriser dans les
commentaires c'est quand je vous parle
du prochain numéro de curieuses ou
magazines et que vous dites mais ouais
mais c'est trop tard pour s'abonner
alors là je vous le dis rien n'avance
voici le sommaire du numéro deux mois de
mars que vous recevrez à partir de début
mars si vous voulez vous abonner le lien
est dans la description etc jusqu'au 17
février que vous pouvez vous abonner
pour celui de mars que c'est comme ça
qu'on fonctionne en fait c'est comme ça
qu'on imprime juste ce qu'il faut et
qu'on peut faire le prix aussi bas merci
encore à noordpeene également d'avoir
sponsorisé cette vidéo le lien est dans
la description norvez tm.com slash
fabien olicard avec lequel vous pouvez
obtenir un abonnement de deux ans plus à
moi gratuite ni tout avec une très
grosse réduction satisfait ou remboursé
pendant 30 jours moi je vous mets deux
autres vidéos d'anciens casquette ici
n'hésitez pas à vous abonner si vous
voulez pas rater le gros énorme
casse-tête qui arrive à plus de 30000
euros je prends en face d'un grip rené
sommes-nous à très bientôt ciao